[Music]
today on drew
secrets will be revealed it's the most
memorable moments from season one you
have changed my life
i had so much that i wanted to talk to
oprah about i actually didn't sleep the
night before it all starts now
[Music]
please welcome drew barrymore
hello
hi everyone the countdown is on for
season two of the drew barrymore show
it all kicks off in exactly one week
monday september 13th and you're not
gonna want to miss it we've got huge
guests
unbelievable surprises
and a live studio audience
i can't wait to see your beautiful faces
here in person who knows you might be on
camera until then let's take a look back
at our favorite moments from season one
with some inside scoop from yours truly
a little berry more behind the scenes if
you will
first up
one of the most impactful moments for me
was interviewing my interview icon
she is daytime royalty truly no one
comes close
and i can only hope to honor her by
doing my best here's my chat with the
indomitable
oprah winfrey
welcome to the show dare i say maybe
you've seen it
yes i have and may i say
dare i say seeing it actually changed my
life you have changed my life you
certainly changed my work life because i
was there for that very first show
where you beamed in cameron and there
you all were and we were you know didn't
know
that you all weren't in the same space
i watched that and i said hey
why can't we do what drew did
and since
why can't we do what you did and since
that time
for
oprah conversations for apple tv
i the first time i did it was with
president barack obama talking about his
book promised land and there we were
sitting right across from each other in
my living room in front of the fireplace
and i i said then this is because of you
drew so thank you
i have to thank you so much because you
didn't need to give us the credit but
you did and for those who are not aware
here's a little
taped piece on the technology of which
oprah and i are talking about
when we launched this show in the middle
of a pandemic we had to get creative
with the magic of technology we came up
with a way to transport our guests from
our la studio right here to new york how
cool is that we knew one person who
thought so too it's oprah
it's oprah it's oprah oh bro
um yes the oprah was inspired to use a
similar green screen technology to
interview guests like chip and joanna
gaines and of course president barack
obama can she see me yet i can't
this is pretty cool technology you got
here oh why thank you mr president and
thank you oprah listen we may not be
able to be in the same room but we can
sure feel like it and look like it
i thank you
so much uh because
i'm i'm gonna be really honest i haven't
really admitted this uh out loud but
it was really scary for me to be
you know
a girl a woman i don't know what i am a
female
asking
for people to take this risk and spend
this money
and ask ourselves these questions and
i'm so grateful
to my bosses that they allowed us to do
this because this was
you know a check and a risk away from
not happening and
i want to ask you
is this where we're going the water is
out of the bottle people are not going
to travel the way they used to people
have gotten comfortable
with interview styles some are going to
show up some aren't you're going to have
access to more people than you ever did
in some ways because the technology it's
all going to be maybe a mixed bag and if
it is don't we have to make it the best
and most compelling television in honor
of the audience yeah i one thousand
percent agree with that and i think
that's why i say you really you
literally have changed my life and when
people say that's it because listen
after drew
i'm not going nowhere and so
the truth is
you're able to have better access and i
think there will certainly be times in
both of our
lives and in our careers when
being directly in front of the person
makes a a world of difference and may
may be necessary but i think
that in terms of having access to
anybody in the world
at any time
what you all did in that first show
um lit the path for changing it forever
and i'm sure we would have done it today
but i you know i'm where there's no
studio so i'm like in the middle of
nowhere out here you need a studio to be
able to do it you really do there was a
studio within 500 miles i would have
done it i'm so glad and may we do it
again in the future because i was so
glad to see you embracing this you
acknowledging us and us moving forward
in this way because it does become a new
normal and it for the girl who felt
really honestly again this is the part i
don't talk about is when you're fighting
for things in business it's not
comfortable especially when they're not
done you feel like the messy one you
feel like the one who might be spending
people's money in a improper way you
don't know if the risk is going to pay
off but you get into your convictions
and you fight for them and so when i saw
you embracing the technology it told
that person who hung up the phone that
day because i remember saying listen you
guys we have got to do this we have got
to find a new way for our future of
television this is not funny we are in a
really unprecedented time and we can't
go on with the home show forever we just
can't you did the thing that i had to do
a thousand times over the years and when
i first started
uh so let me applaud you for doing the
thing
that
every person particularly every woman
needs to learn as soon as possible
your
gut
is right
for you
so when you feel something in your gut
and you think
wow i need to i need to really move on
that that means it is right for you it
doesn't mean that is is right for
everybody else and i think it takes
women in particularly a long long time
to be affirmed in their own beliefs and
that is the reason actually we were the
number one talk show for 25 years
is because i all it always came back to
what do i feel
what do i feel is my real intention in
doing this and i cannot do it if it's
not true to me even if everybody else
says and many times you know
producers would come in with ideas and i
would say
i can't do that i don't i don't know how
i can sit in that chair and keep a
straight face and do that and do that
i'm not gonna be able to do that so
you you i applaud you for going with
your gut because your gut is always
right for you
well i think you've given so much
courage to everyone
especially women
to
fight for what we believe in and
i was going to ask you if you had any
advice
may i ask when you ended your first
season and you knew you were rounding
the corner into season two
what were you telling yourself
i actually was telling myself
uh self you was right
because as
most people don't know this now but
when
we launched
in 1986
i had been a local talk show in chicago
for
two years
what i understood was that there's a
commonality in our human experience and
that people are no different in chicago
than they are in new york than they are
in idaho than they are in rhode island
when it comes to the core now we're in
you know everybody's so divided about
their politics and their beliefs and so
forth but i i still do believe at the
core we are all the same if you ask blue
state red states purple states what
really matters to you the answer is is
the same people care about their
families they care about being able to
live decent lives they care about being
able to do that in comfort and do that
with a sense of peace and um i i still
think in spite of all the craziness in
spite of all the divisions which is what
what everybody talks about all the time
is that we are there we are more alike
than we are different which is a very
famous maya angelou line she used to say
that all the time and
in our humanness we are we all are just
seeking the same things and that's what
this platform the drew barrymore show
offers every day is a chance for those
of us of like-mindedness
those of us who are seeking the joy
who wants to wear some bows
i went extra jaunty for you i was like
bones and flowers it's oprah like
i'm surprised i don't have bells on and
like a boa
i had so much that i wanted to talk to
oprah about i actually didn't sleep the
night before stay tuned for part two of
our chat
[Music]
what i realized is that gail was my
regulation makes me want to cry now
thinking about it
and is still the person in my life i
have
probably three people in my life who are
going to tell me the truth no matter
what here's the bottom line that really
was the hugest
epiphany for me
[Music]
welcome back right now we're diving into
our favorite moments from season one of
the drew barrymore show with some
exclusive host commentary from me your
host and no guest
compares to the queen of daytime miss
oprah winfrey and of course i had to
talk to her about her mutual bff gail
king you know and all her favorite
things but oprah had a new book out
about how our brains process trauma and
well
i love to talk about the tough stuff and
who better to talk about that than with
oprah winfrey please take a look at part
two of our conversation
you now have oprah daily which i happen
to mention to gail that i thought that
the oprah daily the daily word it's so
brilliant
well thank you thank you i wanted i i i
actually came up with that because i
wanted it to be
what i realized is that the oprah show
was a habit just like the drew barrymore
show people are creating a habit around
that and that's what you want that's
your core viewer that's who you're
speaking to every day and
the idea of having a
daily inspiration point a daily quote a
daily
something
that you can rely on to give you just a
little lift you know my whole goal
throughout my life even before i could
articulate it is how do you bring a
light into people's lives how do you let
them see the best of themselves how do
you allow them to grow
into becoming more of who they are which
is what every one of us is actually
aspiring to do whether you can
articulate that for yourself
or not you just you just want to become
more more solid you want to have
the ability to have the fullest
expression of yourself
as a human being
and
you do that by
by habits by by rituals by
creating a space where you can give back
to yourself in a way that allows you to
flourish so we are growing it into
what i
know will be in the future is a daily
spot of inspiration for everybody so
thank you for mentioning that we need
you on the daily i listen to your sirius
xm channel through both my pregnancies
and i
it was it was my daily
north star it was my daily fix
thank you for that it's true i'll never
forget the story you told about gail
getting the water for the traffic cop
and how that moment
was her being such an important and good
parent to her son because she was
showing him the kind of person to be and
that gave me hope because i felt so lost
like what blueprint do i have to pull on
to become a parent i was scared out of
my mind and i thought hearing that story
if i can be an example to my kids maybe
i don't have to draw from my past or
even fight it i can try to be myself and
that
can
that can give me hope to be a good
parent that story literally changed my
life it was um
so thank you for that
well you know gail is to date and she
always says well all parents do then
i'll pass i don't know they don't gail
is to date the best
model parent i have ever seen i've never
seen anybody who
was
more
engaged more
respectful of her children and when she
first had kids you know because we were
best friends in in met a television
station in baltimore and once she
married and had kids i thought well
there's going to be distance in our
relationship because she's not going to
have time to
you know devote to to our friendship
and
it that did not happen but what did
happen every time she was on the phone
with me and one of her children entered
the room she would stop she would put
the phone down
even if she didn't put the phone down
they would be acknowledged she was
present there for them she would say
mommy's on the phone now with annie oh
and morning bear he calls kirby bear
morning she there was an acknowledgement
and and and what i would have to say
over the years a mutual respect and i
know we're going to be talking later
about the subject of what happened to
you but one of the things that dr perry
says in this book is that when children
grow up and they
realize that they are not getting
the respect that they deserve
from their parents
it changes who they are what your kids
want and this is actually
true of everybody
they want to know that you are that
you're here that you see me that you see
me and you hear me and that i matter to
you and that is true for everybody else
in your life too
speaking of this extraordinary book that
i've been reading um and i will forever
have the chart um that dr perry uh put
in the book as far as
uh the upside down triangle the upside
down triangle what you guys talk about
as far as
the impression that children are left
with at such an earlier age than i think
was spoken about in
at least my growing up i i think even
into almost having kids i feel like
everybody kind of went
they won't notice when they're when
they're young and i i
i did not understand why that was the
notion it didn't seem right it didn't
feel right but i wanted to believe it
because that's what so many people had
said here's the bottom line that really
was the hugest
epiphany for me
all these years i've done multiple shows
where people
say exactly what you just said drew oh
they won't remember you know i'm yes i'm
in an abusive relationship and as soon
as you know uh when the kids are young
when they get older i'm gonna move i'm
gonna get out of the relationship the
most damage is done from zero to two
months because that's the time when the
brain is taking in everything and
anybody who's ever had children you all
know this because you get to watch that
whole
language socialization process how do
they learn the word data how do they
learn mama how do they learn spoon how
do they learn so as they're taking in
all of that when the brain is the most
open and receptive they're also taking
in all the other stuff that changed
everything for me in terms of how people
are raising their kids and how we see
that
what you do in front of the youngest
children matters you know i have a
question um which is that uh when when i
was born my dad
he had split with my mom and um i
i just didn't know him he was very
abusive he would come around he would
trash the house
he was scary um
and
you know there are a lot of people and
you share
um a story of what happened the first
night that you stayed with your mom
in milwaukee and for
people who have
um had a parent one or two that did not
want to be in their child's lives for
whatever their reasons were which is
valid to them very hard for a child to
understand
what do you
talk through with yourself
or other people who have had that kind
of start to their lives
who deal with that kind of trauma you
talk about the eyes and the being wanted
and the being set up right what happens
when you're not
so here's the here's the good news about
all of this
because all of us have had things to
happen to our and not to happen to us
in our lives that caused us to feel
unwanted
and
not
important
everybody has at some point in your life
even if you come from the best of
circumstances
it is possible
to take your post-traumatic pain and
turn that into post-traumatic power and
post-traumatic wisdom
i know this for sure
that whatever has happened to you
can
also be for you
if you allow it to be the thing
that has healed me the most is taking
the pain that i
endured suffered survived as a child and
turning that inside out so that is why i
created my school specifically looking
for girls who were just like me who came
from poor backgrounds who came from
dysfunctional backgrounds who
many times felt unwanted unloved how do
i create an environment for them how do
i give back this is how you save
yourself how do i give back that which i
was not given and when you can do that
you begin to fill the hole inside
yourself that giving back
has become
really what my legacy is and i i will
share this with you that i was sitting
with maya angelou
after i'd come back from the opening of
my school and i said oh this is going to
be the school this is going to be my
greatest legacy i mean these girls this
is this is this is this is what my life
was for and she said you have no idea
what your legacy will be and i said oh
no no no no my you she should have been
there it's i'm telling you it's going to
be the school and she said i said
you have no idea
what your legacy
will be
your legacy is every life you touch
your legacy isn't your name on a school
or any other building your legacy is
every life you touch so i say this to
you drew barrymore your legacy this is
what maya said to me everybody who's
ever watched a show and decided i'm
going to go back to school i'm going to
go on a diet i'm going to treat myself
better i'm going to leave an abusive
relationship every life
that you have touched that has
experienced your voice and the power of
your platform that is your legacy
and guess what ladies and gentlemen
we're going to have a little oprah
sprinkled throughout our show this
season as we have partnered with
oprahdaily.com
i am on that feed daily for sure for
some special news features in drew's
news we'll be in collaboration
what a dream come true we'll be right
back
[Music]
welcome back right now i want to talk
about a dear friend who has taught me so
much about food and cooking over the
last
three years she's also a part of the
drew crew which is an amazing group of
our show's contributors alumni if you
will let's take a look at the best of
chef pilar valdez
she's a culinary goddess a woman who
deserves a thunderous standing ovation
my culinary partner in crime she's my
dear friend it's chef pilar valdez
today we're making a peppery steak
with an agridolce sauce let's do it so
we're gonna start with this new york
strip over here okay for this recipe the
reason why i love the new york strip is
because it's tender like a filet and it
has the flavor and fat just like a rib
eye so the first thing we're gonna do is
season up the steak really really well
and then you park that for like an hour
and let it sit okay we have some freshly
crushed black peppercorns you're gonna
lay that on your plate or on top
and you're gonna
press down to adhere so we've seasoned
off both sides and meanwhile
you want your pan
heating over medium to medium-high heat
when your pan is nice and hot you're
going to add some oil and right here
actually we have a steak that has been
searing so it's nice and hot time to
turn it over yeah i like to look at that
beautiful
so
this recipe is gonna cook stove top for
six minutes but just make sure you're
doing essentially the same amount of
time on both sides same amount of time
on both sides and we're going to finish
this steak in the oven okay basically um
one thing to look for um when you're
going into the oven is definitely use an
oven thermometer so we're going to make
the agra dolce sauce real quick we're
going to dump everything in that's two
tablespoons of shallots
two tablespoons shallots all that
roughly chopped cranberries wonderful
and then that is my balsamic over there
some water and then we're going to do
some honey so all you have to do is
basically bring this to a boil and then
simmer it for four minutes until it's
nice and thick and the last little thing
is off the heat we're going to pour in
our mustard
all right so we actually on the side
drew have a steak beautiful steak that
has been resting critical piece to
cooking steak rest your meat for at
least 10 minutes so the last thing to do
is just spoon some of that beautiful
sauce on mm-hmm
oh this cuts
well i guess
i'm sorry
i don't
i just eat
it is really really good
for today the quinoa risotto
with winter squash seared mushrooms and
fresh herbs shall we jump in yes we
shall okay so the first thing you're
going to do is actually roast your
squash and you're going to roast them at
like 400 for about 20 20 to 30 what i
like to do is actually cut the squash
into chunks like this drizzle some olive
oil salt and pepper
stick it in the oven 20 to 30 let it go
and then you're going to take it out and
we're actually going to make a puree so
you're going to take the chunks and
let's pop that in the blender lovely and
then you're going to have some stock
actually oh
there you go a little bit of vegetable
stock here we go
yeah baby
lovely so in the meanwhile we had some
of our quinoa going what i like to do is
i start toasting it first in a dry
skillet it adds this really nice
nuttiness to the dish i have to say i've
not seen people do that yeah and it's
really lovely 45 seconds in a hot dry
pan dry dry that's the key don't that's
the oil in it no no oil no nothing and
then you're going to add some liquid
into that we use vegetable stock and
you're going to bring that to a boil and
then turn it down to simmer and you're
going to mix it and stir it and cook it
for about 18 minutes so we're going to
take our puree
you're going to take some gray which
i've represented
it feels like a hug in a bowl is what i
like to say which is i love a hug and a
bowl pilar
am i going to
start arranging yes please arrange a
range away
and with our trumpet mushrooms they are
trumpet mushrooms i love mushrooms i'm
excited to bring what should be a really
heavy
heavy
dish
to this lightness that is so healthy and
good for your body but still gives all
of that satisfaction so thank you
delicious for the satisfaction baby
yes
i love you love you they taste like
peanut butter and with the salt on top i
mean
oh my god
this is a true original just like you
pilate thank you
i love you i couldn't do it alone i
could only do it with pilar
oh i love you polar so much
we'll be right back
[Music]
even the stars who come on our show get
star struck here's someone we love
talking about a time they met someone
they love the biggest time i was
starstruck i was invited to an after
party at the russian tea room to meet
paul mccartney talking to paul mccartney
is just bizarre because young people
like you know joan used to sit you know
like that and you go
john lennon that's who you're talking
about yeah because you're paul mccartney
yeah and so i just kept like kind of
stuttering just staring and kind of
blinking a lot i was asking all the dumb
questions you asked about the beatles
and paul mccartney i remember i told my
mom i might be going to this my mom's
like if you go to the russian tea room
you have to get a moscow mule
owner comes out can i get you anything i
go
can i have a
moscow mule
thinking paul would be like he's cool do
you want to reform the beatles with you
in it he doesn't even hear me and uh the
rest is uh history and
we currently don't speak
you know what we all freak out over
someone at some point
[Music]
welcome back when we launched the drew
barrymore show
we were in the thick of the pandemic and
so much was uncertain at the time
everything
including school teachers principals and
parents were stretched so thin
they were dealing with the impossible
and on the show we talked to many
educators about how they were dealing
with those unprecedented times and there
was one teacher whose story really stuck
with me and we were lucky enough to help
him continue to help all his students at
eton elementary
take a look at this
your story is so incredible like tell us
about your school first of all yeah so
eton elementary is a school in
washington dc it is in ward 7 northeast
d.c
this community has been
underserved for several years however
this community is filled with such
cultural wealth so i like to describe it
as a culturally wealthy community
although it is a title one school
and majority of the students are
receiving free and reduced lunch but it
is such a loving and caring community um
you know down from the the parents to
the teachers the administration
everyone in that community really
pitches in to make sure that um our
students get what they need and you know
it's been a challenge um you know with
the pandemic starting and teachers
really trying to do everything that they
can the teachers at our school have been
amazing to really trying to connect with
students whether it's through facetime
or twitter instagram or any sort of way
that we can connect with students that's
what we've really been trying and
you know and it's worked out pretty well
for us but you know it is a huge
challenge do you think any of your
students or the other staff members
might be watching right now
um maybe perhaps we are closed from
school today so they could possibly be
watching i'm not sure you know what i
actually know they are because they're
right here in our virtual audience
oh my gosh harmony
jalen
aiden
thanks you guys so much for
hanging out with us and supporting
alejandro okay so you guys are in
virtual learning yes yes what have you
guys been dealing with going virtual
yeah i mean so when the pandemic first
started in march um you know it was a
huge challenge to make sure that
students were still receiving a high
quality education um and so we really
were able to understand um you know how
many students didn't have access to
internet and students didn't have access
to devices um you know and it really was
an eye-opener for a lot of us so you
know we were rushing copying packets to
try to print as much work as we can for
student teachers we're dropping off
supplies at people's homes you know we
were doing all types of things just to
make sure that our students still have
that sense of community that they would
have when they come to our school
building so you know it was a huge
challenge and especially um you know the
internet access piece has been huge um
you know the digital divide is such a uh
big part of you know the conversations
that we're having now um and we're
really seeing how it's affected
you know students that i teach
and also how it's affected you know
students around the country
well um we actually reached out to um
the uh asus um
which is a leading tech company driven
by innovation and quality products for
more than 30 years and they're committed
to providing a variety of education
solutions to connect students and
teachers and they heard your incredible
story and they are giving us um enough
asus chromebooks for every single
student and teacher at ayton elementary
that's amazing i
can't even fathom this this is crazy
meeting drew barrymore getting
computers for our school
computers
higher school
students and teachers oh my goodness and
all that we want to do on this show is
recognize what's happening around us
shine a light on people who are being
such extraordinary human beings
and
thank you to asus we can aid in the
technological aspect that you need as a
tool to be the hero that you are oh my
god thank you so much i i can't even i'm
so happy for everyone at eight on i mean
this community deserves it they are just
such a strong community who you know
every single day the students log on
they have their uniforms on they're in
front of the computer no matter the
connection no matter if they have a
pencil no matter anything and they just
are so passionate about learning so they
deserve this so much they truly do
actually followed up with alejandro a
few weeks later to present him with 50
000
and a full scholarship for him to the
national university's master's program
gosh he so deserved it and more by the
way he also won teacher of the year in
his district so i'm just saying we'll be
right back
[Music]
welcome back today we're revisiting our
favorite moments from season one of the
drew barrymore show with a little extra
behind-the-scenes info from yours truly
it's the barrymore cut now my hands down
favorite part of the show every day is
drew's news and last season i had one
very special guest join me at the desk
gail king
now this segment aired as like 12
minutes total i think but we talked for
probably i would say for more than
almost an hour i could have talked to
her for another hour i love gail
take a look
i get the first headline they say so
here we go
starting with the latest vaccine news
cbs news reports that pfizer has
completed a study and found their
vaccine is safe and 100 effective for
kids this is big ages 12 to 15.
so pfizer plans to file with the fda for
emergency use of the vaccine for kids as
young as 12. you know i know drew that
there's still some vaccine hesitancy but
that's changing
you know i've heard people say why
didn't i never got the flu shot the
difference is if you didn't get the flu
shot it only affected you if you don't
get this vaccine it affects all of us
and the people around you so i think
this is very exciting especially for
kids because they can go back to school
i don't know about frankie and olive but
aren't they sick of just looking at a
little zoom zoom everyone has hit a
fatigue level that is so real
and we know we're here for a little
longer so the sooner we get vaccinated
the better it will be out of it back to
life have you i've had mine i've had
mine too
in all of this um
difficult
roads that we are all navigating i have
come to have a new re appreciation for
entertainment yep me too i think when
the world falls apart you just think ugh
entertainment uh you know bigger bigger
picture problems
and then you're at home for a long time
and you just need an assistant
entertainment please exactly so a show
like bridger tin the steamy netflix hit
that broke records is coming back for
season two it's been a personal favorite
of mine glamour reports that the show
plans to take some real-life inspiration
from former royals harry and megan and
in season two the characters simon and
daphne newlyweds new parents will go
through some struggles similar to megan
and harry i think being royals having
public opinion being new parents are
sort of the similar through lines
gail i can't think of anyone we've
looked to for the north star other than
you and oprah for all of the truths from
harry and megan
i think that interview opened up
conversations that many people weren't
prepared to have or didn't want to have
but i think ultimately it's about a
family that wants to be united and be
together and i'm hoping that that that
will be the case and have those
difficult conversations yes yes
sometimes conversations are very
difficult yeah i i really admire hearing
all the details and opening up that
important conversation and
really making history in a conversation
that was refusing to be had for
centuries so i'm very happy that the lid
is off and
it there's nothing healthy about not
having those tough conversations there's
nothing healthy when you don't talk
so let's all wish that for all involved
in that particular story okay gail your
story up okay my turn again
this is a good one a writer cosmopolitan
recently admitted that she misses
eavesdropping on awkward first dates i
love this you know we all miss going out
to restaurants yeah you do with your
friends you also miss albert
sitting your strangers and listening to
their private conversations
can you relate to this hello my name is
gail yes
because haven't you been in a restaurant
and you hear a conversation between a
couple in particular
and it's not going so well or you've
been on a train or you're even walking
down the street and you get a snippet of
something i've actually turned around
turn around and walk behind the person
just so i could hear the end of the
story are you one of those people well
you love nancy drew so yeah i do perfect
sleuthing i do i really miss it it was
funny tony um decopo on the show
literally was like yeah you know you
guys should
try not dating apps and meeting in
person i'm like have you read the room
the last year nobody's in person you
know of course but i do think that his
point is is important because i think we
will get back to that
um and i tried a dating app for a second
you did i did inspired by bridgerton i
was like i gotta put myself back out but
did you go as drew yeah did you go as
your drew face you have to be honest no
way to start anything on deception i
know but drew i would do it i just don't
want people to know that it's me i think
also right now i'm a little confused
like is it my girlfriends i miss because
for me the truth is and i did go on a
date with a guy and he was like you know
and i was like no no no don't listen
kids work girlfriends alone time fifth
is the guy like but wait you started to
say he said you know i what was we we
were both talking about like why
relationships are complicated and um and
i was like i i think i'm really clear
about it it's sort of my fifth priority
and i
understand it's a problem yeah i guess
it is yeah
all right well today we are tackling the
spring cleaning on the show and in that
spirit we must debunk the latest viral
underwear mask videos on tick tock are
claiming that you must replace your
underwear every six to nine months
and i'm here to tell you
absolutely false also like how many
pairs of underwear are we talking about
well i mean i just think number one
i have you know there
i have bras that sometimes you're
putting a safety pin i know that's bad i
know that's right but i don't understand
why you'd get rid of it six to nine
months because it's still in pretty good
condition
i think if you have multiple pairs
you're probably okay
well i have multiple pairs don't you i
do i wear the same pair of panties and
that in that case i would suggest
hygienically disposing of them but yeah
women in home ask doctors and experts
and they say there is no expiration date
so good it's not like a toothbrush i
believe they're underpants and look at
the variety that you're showing
see those are pretty i feel like i
should rock something more like that i
feel like that's why we're single we
don't want to wear granny panties no no
wear granny no i don't really granny
panties no
i'm not wearing little thongs either but
no i'm not wearing granny pants a
sensible sexy panty
does sensible and sexy go together drew
probably not probably not
oh gayle come back to the drew's news
desk as soon as possible
i love you
now don't go anywhere because up next
we're going to let you in on a little
secret about season two of the drew
barrymore show
[Music]
we're back
[Music]
the new season of drew premieres
september 13th
[Music]
welcome back
season two of the drew barrymore show
kicks off monday september 13th one week
from today and man is it going to be
huge so huge in fact
it's by coastal
we're doing shows in new york and we're
doing shows in los angeles that's right
i'm going back to my hometown
to celebrate the people and places where
i grew up it's very personal actually
and very invitational
over the course of the premiere we're
going to celebrate your hometowns as
well because as they say
there's no place like home
and it's all happening one week from
today the season two premiere of the
emmy-nominated drewberry moore show my
goodness
make sure to come join us tune in thanks
for watching see you soon
hopefully
[Music]
you